hello and welcome the shape of the u.s.
race is finally clear Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump looks set to be their
party's nominees the battle is joined
and it's already turning nasty the
combative Trump has promised a radical
change in American politics and that
sounds good too many people in America
Clinton on the other hand has promised
continuity but that's not the kind of
campaign platform that gets a lot of
voters excited this presidential
campaign could be one of the most brutal
and modern American history that's our
topic today on quadriga and we're going
to talk about it with three people who
watch us politics very closely it's a
pleasure to welcome cristiana Maya she
is a correspondent for the morning show
of the German public network ard and she
formally reported for ard from
Washington she says we look with shock
and no awe at a u.s. campaign where many
people follow a man who would be fired
from any school for his hateful racist
and aggressive remarks the last thing
the world needs is Donald Trump in the
White House at it's a pleasure to
welcome Rica hobbits she works as an
online editor at site online and she
writes about us politics of the current
presidential election she says one of
the biggest challenges for Hillary
Clinton in this race is to convince
voters who feel that the American Dream
is dead that her conventional qualities
as a candidate matter more than Donald
Trump's populism and a warm welcome as
well to Erik Kirschbaum he's originally
from New York now works as a
correspondent for the Los Angeles Times
in Berlin he says there's a lot of anger
and frustration in the United States and
in Europe and that manifests itself in
surprisingly strong support for
anti-establishment candidates like Trump
Sanders and also like Hoffa and lepen
but it's hard to imagine American
selecting anyone but Clinton in November
Erik Kirschbaum this race has been so
full of surprises that I have to at
least put the question can we really be
sure that it's going to be Clinton
against Trump when it comes to the
general election or is it possible that
there could be more surprises at store
in store at the party's conventions in
July well after all the surprises we've
had it looks like it will be Trump
versus Clinton there could be
last-minute surprises but it's really
really unlikely Clinton Clinton got
enough delegates with the winners in
California the other day it would take a
miracle to prevent Trump from being the
nominee so it looks like Clinton versus
trump in November even though Trump is
once again alienating the party bosses
the party elite the the people he had
tried so hard to curry favor with lately
like Paul Ryan who of course is majority
a speaker in the house and who has now
said Trump's latest remarks a racist but
he thinks he probably will vote for him
it is remarkable that Trump in a moment
he needs to be uniting his party around
him is just causing more division by
attacking a judge and that's something
that went a bit too far calling a judge
a Mexican just raised all kinds of
ghosts the Trump doesn't really need
right now and a lot of Americans sort of
in the middle of the road orbit
frightened when politicians and would-be
presidents start attacking the judiciary
it was a total own goal for Trump and
it's not going to do and I couldn't do
many any good Christian amaya Hillary
Clinton would be the first woman
president of the u.s. she is the first
female nominee for president she was
celebrating that very openly this week
but not all that many Americans and
perhaps not as many as one might expect
are celebrating with her and supporting
her why is that a good question yeah
it's probably because she is regarded as
the person who stands for establishment
and that seems to be a bad thing in
America obviously because so many people
seem to be unhappy with the established
politics and it falls back on her that
he has been in power of a long time I
mean she has the experience Trump
doesn't have and that doesn't seem to be
to her advantage which is kind of
interesting to watch on the other hand
many women obviously and
many immigrants are really behind her
and I think she's got a very good chance
to actually succeed even though she
comes across as maybe a little bit huh
maybe not as warm as people would like
her to be but then again you don't go
drinking beer and coffee with a
candidate right that really surprised me
last the last few weeks as in New York
and California how unenthusiastic people
are about Hillary Clinton I'm really
surprised by that I would have thought
there'd be more excitement about a woman
candidate first woman president but
there's not there there's no there's no
real buzz for Hillary right now but do
you think Chris Jeremiah that could
change now that the general election
phase is starting and in other words can
she also win over the young people who
supported Bernie Sanders I think that's
absolutely crucial I mean obviously
they're trying to nudge send us into
behind her so if he would more or less
give up and then say alright I'm going
to support her and if he can get some of
his issues across for example education
very important issue for young people
and if he doesn't come across as the old
grumpy old man who was not able to give
up if all that happens I think there
could be more enthusiasm for Hillary
Clinton that has been kind of divided
between obviously the young people in
the older people so I'm rather
optimistic actually lose your habits you
mentioned people in America who feel
that the American Dream is dead in that
opening statement that i quoted of
course those are the people to whom both
Sanders and Trump have been appealing
Trump of course is seen by many of those
as an outsider with a fresh and
authentic point of view and has the
self-made men but in fact he's neither
no of course he's not but he's very
smart and appealing to people that have
I think a lot of frustration and anger
they are frustrated with the politicians
in Washington DC he appeals to people
that are older that a male that a wide
that had the American Dream in their
mind that they can have one drop in
their lifetime buy a house by a car
support the children through college and
then that's it but that life in America
is over there is no longer the American
dream they wish for in Donald Trump he
just stands then say well if you wrote
for me
I'm bringing the American Dream back i'm
bringing back the 80s which is not going
to happen but he's so smart and doing so
and so he's appealing to very certain i
think demographic which will not be
there in future elections to come so
this is his shot and he's doing it very
well so this time just exactly like that
in germany and france everywhere
disenfranchised people who are going for
the easy access so it's really easy
answers for very complicated questions
political questions and i think it is
obviously very easy to follow a person
who comes across like that you know what
you don't realized what the world really
all about and he also says well you are
afraid and if you vote for me all your
fears are going to get away and i think
the american society has become a very
afraid society they've been like afraid
of terror afraid of different nations
different people their next door
neighbor african-americans i mean
there's a lot of fear in the society i
believe and i talked a lot of people
then they're all afraid of so many
things and he stands there and say well
i'm not afraid of anyone or anything and
if you vote from me i'm going to be the
strong person in the white house but
here's something very puzzling many are
disillusioned with the politicians in
Washington they say they they are lying
they are promising things they don't
deliver the fact is Trump has promised
lots of things he didn't deliver he
started a school for real estate brokers
where there has been clear fraud and
that has been reported upon and yet
nothing seems to stick his supporters
stick with him despite the fact that
that he has been shown to be telling
lies how can that be yeah I'm surprised
by that as well but i think it is has
been reported but i don't know of the
people that support him necessarily are
reading the big piece in the new york
times or the LA Times on what he has
done wrong and then there's our outlets
like Fox News or like just giving him
airtime and airtime and airtime and I
think it's also part of the problem is
the meteor that has been not very good
in reporting on what he has promised and
not opposed to what he has said what
what he didn't do and so I think part of
what we have to see now is a very much
more critical meteor landscape and like
a civil society in America said that
says well we cannot vote for Donald try
if we want to live to what we have
established like equality for minorities
equality for gay people all all that
issues are so much important in there so
on the line so I think we need to stand
up and address that more and make people
here that one thing is for sure the
media have been keen to report some of
the more outrageous statements that have
been made by Donald Trump let's take a
look Hillary Clinton has to go to jail
okay chance to go to jail I will leave
it to the psychiatrist to explain his
affection for tyrants Hillary Clinton is
a weak person Hillary Clinton is totally
scripted he is temperamental e unfit to
hold an office that requires knowledge
stability and immense responsibility
instead of saying crooked Hillary which
is a very accurate description I wonder
if I could say you know remember lion
the lion we all know the tools Donald
Trump brings to the table bragging
mocking composing nasty tweets she does
not look presidential that I can tell
you she doesn't this is not a president
I believe the person the Republicans
have nominated for president cannot do
the job so Erik Kirschbaum Harry Hillary
Clinton talked there about the tools
that Donald Trump brings to the table he
has made it clear that among those tools
will be vicious vicious attacks he is
not afraid to hit below the belt he has
done it plenty in the past he has
indicated he's perfectly happy for
example to make Bill Clinton's past
affairs grist for his mill won't Hillary
Clinton be held to a different standard
can she really fight with the same kind
of weapons or will she be at a
disadvantage in this kind of what could
become really a mud-wrestling match well
it stays nasty like this she will have a
problem but she's already shown that
she's gonna take on Trump where he's
most weak where's lack of knowledge of
world affairs she'd give a really good
speech last week about foreign policy
they went done really what
we can't forget the Trump won more votes
in the Republican primary than any other
Republican before he's got a lot of
people on his side I mean people in
America East always complain Oh only
fifty percent of the people vote now
there is a much higher turnout and now
we see were these people who never voted
before or voting so maybe it was better
that voter turnout was lower it but so
Trump has pulled it off but things that
were working for him in the past winning
these voters in a primary could hurt him
in the general election because he's got
to win these middle-of-the-road voters
and he's behind in so many states um
that it looks right now like an easy win
for the Democrats if unless Trump games
10 percentage points across the board
Clinton as as Eric just pointed out did
in fact make quite a strong speech last
week clearly she had been doing some
thinking some training and also
undoubtedly had a lot of consultants at
her side telling her or working with her
on how to address the kind of polemics
that that Trump has been throwing her
way she is a very seasoned politician
Christian amaya she has been through
some very tough tests in her very
lengthy career do you think that will
stand her in good stead will she be able
to put up and with and perhaps even
trounce these kind of attacks I'm pretty
sure she will because she already showed
that she can keep her calm you know she
stays rational whereas he goes out of
his way to be nasty and awful and
horrible she is just composed she
doesn't use bad language like he does so
I think she if she attacks him I mean
that this one's that there's his
personality on the one side which you
really think is very easy to attack and
on the other side there's this
inexperienced in political matters so
she has a lot of things to go for and
when you talk about the middle of the
road vota you know the middle people
they don't like that when their children
here nasty language I'm television I'm
totally surprised how the Americans can
actually put up with that I mean if you
would use that language in your normal
circumstances your normal life you know
you be you would not go to a normal
school you know as people would
certainly expel you and you and the
parents would be called in and sitting
old with Trump I mean it's been
entertaining and exciting for a while
something completely different but it's
going to get old by no
amber and I think you're right i think
trump is going to have a hard time with
this this crazy profane vulgar message
people are getting tired of it or will
get tired of it thanks leo class on the
other hand Rica habits Trump has had a
very decided advantage in media coverage
every nasty tweet that he sends out gets
picked up by the mainstream media and
then retweeted and discussed and and in
fact the president of CBS went so far as
to say Trump is bad for the country but
it's very very good for CBS they have
had revenues like never before thanks to
all of the interest in Donald Trump what
the media themselves need to be doing
going forward to in fact create a level
playing field here or won't there be one
well I think it's difficult because on
the one hand you want to report on
everything that is going on and that is
your job as a journalist and so but I
think what the huffington post for
example did they just like beneath every
article in donald trump they say Donald
Trump has been making risen racist
remarks and has been unpolite so they
stayed very clearly where their
editorial opinion on him is I don't know
if that is the way to go I think you
have to be more rational and covering
the election I mean this is a very nasty
race and it's going to be a lot more
nasty until november i think it's going
to be very interesting to see the first
national debate where Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump be up on one stage for
the first time debating on issues I
think that is going to be very
interesting to see because Donald Trump
cannot be as well as he has been so I
think that is going to be very
interesting and they don't think he'll
talk about the size of Hillary Clinton's
hands well we were you hope he doesn't
but I mean you can never be sure about
him I mean he can pull up anything
apparently but I think coming back to
your question about the media I think
sometimes it might help to just take a
step back before you just reach retweet
Facebook something just for the
attention and just for the audience
which I mean it's just but isn't it
isn't it America itself that brought
that on to itself I mean having
elections as big show that is run on the
media as a show event almost with all
that money involved and everybody who
has to go out of their way to attract
attention so
in a way it's that you got a person who
who delivers the big show you know there
he is and obviously they're cynical
enough to say okay the rates are great
you know let's go for it that's one side
of how perhaps the u.s. brought this on
itself another side Erik Kirschbaum
might be polarization both in the sense
of polarization in Washington that meant
that in eight years all the parties did
in Congress with fight with each other
leading to the disillusion and secondly
polarization of the media meaning even
if there's critical reporting a lot of
those Trump supporters maybe aren't
going to see it yeah i mean the
Millennials get their information from
different platforms from facebook and
twitter and things like that and yeah
it's a total different racist time and
there is this polarization you talk
about it's hard to break so that's why i
kinda like Sanders I think would have
had a very difficult time if he were to
become president because he'd have a
very hostile Congress whereas Clinton is
somebody that could hopefully work with
it with the Congress dominated by the
Republicans and at least get them some
things accomplished it's a crazy
election it's unlike anything we've seen
for a long time but the Democrats have
won every election except 2004 going all
back to nineteen eighty-eight the
Republicans only 11 so the electoral
advantage the electoral college
advantage the Democrats have is pretty
pretty enormous it's something that
people who are worried about Trump
should really think about that it's not
one big election like in Germany it's 50
individual elections and the Democrats
have a pretty good head start at this
point I totally agree but I think it's
very easy to say well the Democrats are
going to make it i think it's so
dangerous that Donald Trump even came
that close or might come that close to
the White House and we don't know what
happens until November and I think if
there's one major tag in Europe or even
in America we don't want to think about
that but just just imagine one big
terrorist attack i think that would just
give him a major advantage let's briefly
think about what Oh Donald Trump in the
White House might mean in terms of
foreign policy of course Hillary
Clinton's presumptive advantage is that
she had experiences Secretary of State
but Donald Trump did hold what he called
a major foreign policy address recently
and more or less outlined where he would
go although it left many
people somewhat in doubt let's take a
closer look North Korean leader Kim
jong-un shunned by the international
community because of his nuclear
development program but Donald Trump
says he'd be prepared to talk to Kim
North Korea recently praised Trump as a
wise politician Trump also says he'd
like to have good relations with Moscow
and Beijing we desire to live peacefully
and in friendship with Russia and China
we have serious differences with these
two nations and must regard them with
open eyes but we are not bound to be
adversaries Clinton slams Trump's
foreign policy statements as dangerously
incoherent he praises dictators like
Vladimir Putin and picks fights with our
friends perhaps Trump can use these new
male bonding efforts to resolve
long-standing international disputes so
is he a hawk or is he a dove Cristiano
Maya who knows I don't know if he knows
because obviously he has no experience
he has no idea about foreign politics
what he said is for example that in NATO
they don't want to have keep the leading
role all the other countries would have
to pay more so they come all these
remarks and you don't don't really know
where does it come from is anything has
thought through or not or is it coming
from his stomach basically you so it's a
worrying thought that he should be the
one who actually holds the button yes as
Hillary Clinton has said who would have
the codes and nuclear codes and a Kish
bum according to trump in that major
foreign policy address i mentioned he
has written a book called the art of the
deal and he says what we need to do is
take a more transactional approach to
things you have to be ready to walk away
from the table and then you can get
people to do what you want is that a
clear strategy that you think would
bring gains visa vie let's say China or
Russia no it's a dangerous strategy
might work for a businessman but as
president where there's a lot of
countries looking at the United States
for leadership it's a really scary thing
he's already upset financial markets by
talking about renegotiating Treasuries
and things like that the United States
Treasuries have been the most reliable
placed for a four
foreign investors to put their money for
centuries and he's he threatens to mess
that up with just a few unconsidered
word so he really as you said don't
doesn't have an idea and it's a scary
prospect for a lot of a lot of America's
allies let's talk about the US and
Europe going forward both both
candidates have actually said that they
would perhaps expect more from Europe at
least in regard to contributions to NATO
contributions to supporting defense
within say Eastern Europe and and so on
Europe on the other hand is often
looking to the US with a mix of
resentment of us power and at the same
time wishing somebody would fix the
Middle East what do you think would
either of these candidates do things
significantly differently would either
of them bring the US back into the role
of world policemen well with Trump I
would agree you just cannot tell you
cannot tell what he's going to do he
doesn't seem to have like smart advisers
we don't know who he would pick as a
vice president which would be a very
interesting thing to look at if we
already knew what he would have in mind
for that Hillary on the other hand I
think is very reliable she would be a
very reliable partner for Europe and the
European Union and I mean it's always
like a give and take and I think if you
with us says well Europe has to give
more in regard to NATO you can question
whether the US is doing enough or
regarding the refugee crisis so I think
there's going to be a lot of talks and
negotiation but with Hillary Clinton
this is going to be more reliable I mean
Trump's call for Europe to do more with
NATO to spend two percent of their gdp
is actually a pretty good thing that's
one of the things Trump has said that
does make sense that in Europe they have
been dragging their feet the US has been
been carrying the ball for NATO for a
long long time and European countries
like Germany just talked about doing
more for NATO but they don't so Trump is
thinking out of the box a bit on some
issues and of all the things Trump has
come up with that's one that did catch
my eye is that something that makes
sense my eyes is that he likes he's
already looking forward to his talks
with Putin so you wonder you know are
they going to join the sauna together or
what are they going to do I mean is that
level where he thinks he's right so
apart from the NATO thing
you're right on that one of course and
other people have said that before of
course that the two percent we're
supposed to contribute we don't
contribute but what why is your
pregnancy tornado Allah that's a long
story um I think it will be difficult to
change but it will probably gradually
change you say that Hillary Clinton
would definitely be more reliable but in
fact one of her advisors has said that
key motto for Hillary Clinton is when in
doubt act couldn't that lead to a more
activist military role that in fact
might be uncomfortable could be um I
think what helped hillary clinton in
some regard is that Bernie Sanders has
been in the ways for so long I mean he
made her a better candidate and more
from a European standpoint left-wing
candidate she had to address more
left-wing issue so my hope kind of is
that the Democratic Party and President
Clinton would not forget totally about
all of those aspects but of course she
has shown that she is a strong she has a
strong voice on foreign policy and that
she is ready to act I mean we all
remember the picture when osama bin
laden was killed and she was sitting
right next to obama and I mean she's
ready to react and she voted on the
Iraqi war so we don't have to forget
about that so here comes the moment that
all presenters love and guests hate
which is that I'm going to ask you to
give us forecast who you think is going
to win this election and you're you
don't have to just give me one name you
are allowed to explain for one or two
sentences why you've made your choice
Erik Kirschbaum I think Trump's gonna
have a hard time uden finding a vice
president candidate some people who
already said they're not interested but
I think Clinton's gonna win and it's
gonna be a landslide a very big victory
I totally agree I think she might not be
loved but she's respected she's reliable
and that will actually carry her through
eventually so she's gonna win I have to
agree Hillary Clinton is going to make
it her conventional qualities will
reassure the American public that she is
a good president so what could change
that calculus all three of you have
given your vote for Clinton what if
anything could lead to a different
outcome if she has a big lead
a problem in the fall with the emails
the Secretary of State if she ends up in
court and has some problems with that
that could be a big spanner in the works
for her if Bernie Sanders doesn't do the
right thing and bow out gracefully that
could also cause problems if the left
wing voters of Bernie Sanders don't
rally around Clinton that could be a
problem if Trump were to suddenly get
his act together and start sounding more
presidential and unify his party it
could be it could be a closer race but
it doesn't look like it's gonna happen
right now so you mentioned all the
reasons already but I think yeah if the
Trump would change his personality all
of a sudden that might be dangerous I
think all the other points yes dangerous
but probably will not cost her the
victory I think changing his personality
would help him but it's not going to
happen and as I mentioned before I think
if we would have to see a major
terrorist attack i think that would play
in his favor i don't think that made him
necessarily win the white house but that
would make it much closer thank you very
much to all of that all of you for being
with us here on quad Riga and thanks to
all of you out there for tuning in hope
to see you next time bye
you
you